growing new concerns about the
coronavirus right here in the United
States because we now have the first
case with no immediate links to
worldwide travel or a related illness
California health officials say that
patient has been isolated it's one of 16
known cases in the u.s. more than 82,000
illnesses are reported globally more
than 40 different countries with some
taking drastic measures to prevent a
spread this morning Saudi Arabia closed
all its major Islamic holy sites to
foreigners and Japan said it will close
all of its schools for a month to keep
corona virus from spreading back here in
the US Carter Evans is outside that
hospital in Sacramento where that new
American patient is being treated Carter
why is this case causing so much concern
well it's a big concern because there
have only been two other cases of
person-to-person transmission of the
virus here in the US and both of those
occurred after exposure to a family
member who had been to China we don't
know how the person here got infected
with this virus right now and that's a
big concern for health officials who are
trying to stop its spread there's
probably other cases out there in the
community that we don't know about
doctors at the UC Davis Medical Center
are concerned the patient here might
just be the first of many infected by
someone else in the general population
the individual was transferred here last
Wednesday already intubated and on a
ventilator he or she wasn't tested for
coronavirus until sunday and the results
came back positive
just yesterday it's the first case of
what doctors are calling community
transmission that suggests that we don't
know where they got it from so the
person who exposed them probably exposed
others efforts to combat the highly
contagious virus are growing coast to
coast your gown goes on first hospital
workers outside New York are being
trained to protect themselves as more
than 80 people who may have been exposed
in China are currently in isolation in
their homes for a state of high
vigilance high readiness all elements to
the city government to address this
crisis Los Angeles is also taking
extraordinary precautions
we're disinfecting LAX every hour
we're making sure that those points of
entry are as secure as we can possibly
make them Villanova University is
telling its students studying abroad in
Italy that they need to return home now
because of the increase in cases they're
also saying goes for Sacramento State
with its students in South Korea telling
them to come back right now we expect to
learn more about the patient here at a
news conference later today Tony all
right Carter thank you very much